- selling nuts -
I generally get up around seven when I
sleep well first thing I do I walk
straight to the kitchen I put the coffee
in the microwave
I'm write in a journal every day and my
journals to me are everything love [ __ ]
cowboy the threat and the low for all
people places things animals assertive
fans sex such as a form of communication
over time no matter you know it's kind
of like you're just constantly shooting
for the stars looking at the big picture
and you know you're basically your life
follows the pattern of your thoughts
life is tough it's hard to stay
motivated especially if you're really
keeping yourself moving people are
saying you work out on all that kinda
good Pete the beard servants I'm driven
to succeed to get publicity to get
numbers to be seen in to share you know
motivate inspire influence and impact
everyone after about an hour sometimes
two hours of that I take a shower and
basically just get ready for work most
people don't know I have the fastest
cave and eat well I have a huge
underwear collection
my wife is constantly putting them on
boards painting them and I'm constantly
getting a fresh supply of mediums when
they're brand new it's like putting on a
new suit you're like I feel confident
today
[Music]
towards Hana high school I would imagine
somebody told me about this book
unlimited power
up to that point I was a crazy wild kid
like trouble all the time but going to
the courthouse for you name it 50
different juvenile misconduct stuff I'm
reading the book and this guy says I
could be anything I want I can be rich
successful at everything else and
somebody actually instead of saying I
can't do something said I could do
something I was trying to be a country
singer a model and actor or body
builders when I went to Venice Beach
California 1998 to shoot for Playgirl
magazine I went and played on the beach
and a cowboy outfit with my clothes was
ignored the entire day the photographer
who was shooting me naked said watch you
play in your underwear I knew when I got
in my underwear I did it nobody came
over I knew it right then and there so
that was you know the birth of Naked
Cowboy if you will I went back to
Cincinnati my hometown did the same
thing I did at Venice Beach I got my
underwear boots at Hatton the parking
garage came out and played people went
crazy took pictures and then the police
arrested me and I got like a $69
something like that citation but I got
on the morning show the next day so I
paid $69 and I'm on TV and I'm talking
about how I'm gonna be the most
celebrated Entertainer of all time I'm
advertising naked cowboy I basically
went from Cincinnati all the way to Key
West Florida they got the news almost in
every city I call the police pay on the
news how could I not and then a friend
suggested going east because he said I
could get arrested every two or three
hours instead of every ten or 12 hours
the cities are closer together
I went east for that reason happy to go
to New York happen to fall on the Times
Square
got a cheap hotel and came back for the
second day two days became 16 years my
goal was never to be a street performer
and get a dollar and a dollar and a
dollar I mean ultimately that's what
it's come to you know but the whole
point was the you know
get very successful three to brand and
sell products worldwide and get checks
in the mail for the rest of my life it
was 18 years nearly every single day my
routine of going in and everything I
like I'd like to say it gets easier all
the time but the winners a tough time of
year for a naked cowboy if it's 20
degrees like it's been lately you're
looking at 30 minutes two hours in the
garage 30 minutes when I come out of the
cold especially your body's all tighten
its tensing working out is a stress
reliever just warms you up
[Music]
when I started it all duyan City playing
a song or two all my gigs cut early and
now they know what to do I tried country
back even blues still my plans they fell
through so I hitched a plane better
speech in teens answers they for seven
hours barely made a pop culture I was
ignored even booed so I dropped my
balloons brown to undertake it come on
keepin it real for you I'm the name eat
kebab you gotta do what you gotta do I'm
the new defense a [ __ ] hell does that
hit you
swinging man but in the old days and uh
plane to st. Anne to but I'm on the
charts for TV news doing best what I do
round three I'm burning each cowboy
keep it to freefall you I'm gonna kick a
ball you gotta do what you gotta do
[Applause]
[Music]
I think about I would say anywhere from
sixty to a hundred dollars no matter
what yeah everybody thinks I'm a
multimillionaire because I'm so well
known so famous I'd literally was out
there for eight three years and never
even took a dollar
time-life they did a piece explaining
how I made a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars a year and that's about more
accurate these days but that's working
almost every day with rent at $2,000 my
car exclusively for business at $1,000 a
month
car insurance health insurance parkings
almost $1,000 in the city where I park
so making a hundred and fifty thousand
in revenue I'm also spending like 80
thousand dollars then I got a deal with
Blue Island Oyster Company now this is
what we're really looking for and we
have naked cowboy oysters that are sold
in over 700 restaurants in the United
States I've gotten checks as much as
$20,000 a month naked cowboy wines we
just signed this deal in Hood River
Oregon when I decided to get into the
wine business I knew only one company
would fit the bill
naked winery when we are making cowboy
hot sauce I also do personal appearances
at $1,000 an hour in the city 10,000 out
of the city for a day just did Germany
for Volkswagen not bad for an honest
day's living well I think I'll retire
well at this point in my life I just
turned 47 I think I could be old and do
it it's it's more about being funny it
would be funny no matter what my goal
has always been to get rich and famous
so until I get rich I'm not quit and
that's for sure
[Applause]
you